what treasures captain is he working for
you
great year for the xbox one some
fantastic games those are our five
nominees for best xbox one video game of
the year 2014 ah let's first of all
start with shadow of Mordor you can talk
a lot about the Nemesis system it comes
up a lot but outside of that outside of
that sort of wonderfully unique mechanic
mortar is a solid game and it builds on
like the front builds on the foundations
of a bunch of other great games yeah
totally I mean it's hard to escape the
shadow of Assassin's Creed when you play
shadow of Mordor but what's really
interesting but what's really
interesting to me about that I made a
joke but really interesting about that
to me it's the best assassins creed game
that came out in 2014 oh and you know
but I gotta say it doesn't not you know
it builds on it's just interesting ways
and one of my favorites is that it makes
the game a challenge particularly early
on you can't just fight your way out of
twenty thousand orcs descending upon you
that one touch alone makes all the
difference because what it does is it
infuses meaning into every mechanic but
you don't have to think about in similar
games suddenly it's not just about
having lots of choices it's about having
lots of meaningful choices and that that
one look at making it a challenge makes
all the difference in the world make it
a challenge and suddenly all the
mechanics have no meaning they never I
felt like I was like a horse in red dead
redemption when I played that game and
it was like took me a long time of like
just I could kill everyone are you ever
gonna die die broke lately and then I
was like oh another game you really
enjoyed this year as well was a dragon
age inquisition oh yeah speaking of
horses uh so like a exploration in that
game is just so interesting I mean it's
not you know it's not your Skyrim
sprawling open-world go where everyone
all the time but like you have these
these areas like the hinterlands we're
seeing here that are just so rich with
things to do and with sights to see and
they're big enough that you have that
moment that I like this is the bar that
I measure and
sort of open world exploration by it's
like I see a cool thing way off in the
distance can I go to that cool thing and
find cool things there and find cool
things on the way yes alright this is
awesome i am weigh in on it interesting
year for the xbox one were was seeing on
our nominees here is that not a lot of
exclusives being mentioned here you
could guess you could call it a platform
exclusive or at least a microsoft
exclusive but for sure titanfall was one
of the best games that came out on xbox
yeah and it was really one of those
standouts that you know had some
exclusivity to it you know it you know
and it wasn't available on playstation
put it very much or wii u right but no I
mean this is free this is a game that
tried something new in the campaign way
because it was like listen we are
setting out to make a multiplayer
shooter we're going to throw in a
campaign experience I don't think the
campaign experience was super good but
then again it was just a bunch of
multiplayer matches the multiplayer
action in the game is great so it's just
you're you know a playing this game
multiplayer is unlike playing any other
game multiplayer I mean the speed you
can compare to call of duty the mobility
you could compare to a brink and I was
blathering deeply you're like the idea
behind it but the execution here and the
this year options of what you can do
with that mobility with your sort of
combat positioning just makes it this
evergreen experience and what I love the
better was it reminded me of the early
xbox 360 games where every now and again
you got that one game like sort of Gears
of War where everyone got us and the
week that came out everyone who had an
xbox one was playing titanfall and
everyone in the office was clambering
those who haven't gotten an xbox one
we're clambering to the stores to get it
and I think that's the one thing that we
sort of i'm looking forward to next year
as much as possible and there hasn't
been too many games this year on xbox
one that have actually done that
titanfall was absolutely one of them and
another game would share which is not a
exclusive on xbox one that is mentioned
in our top five games of the year is
once again metal gear solid ground
zeroes and have any folks played and I
feel like I've been talking about ground
zeroes all day today but you're so
eloquent I know you just tell it I love
it it's I it again I thought it was
maybe oh it's going to be like a
prologue version 2 and metal gear solid
5 but it turns out it's not just like
a demo or it's not just a truncated
version or it's not a game that you can
play in you know an hour and complete it
and be done with it you can if you want
to but to do that would be like playing
the first chapter of any game and then
stop and playing for me ground zeroes
was a really enjoyable experience it's
one that I piled hours upon hours
probably the two dozen arrows into in
total and it looks fantastic it showed
off the new next-gen hardware really
well and apart from it being just a
wonderful taste of what's to come with
metal gear solid 5 and I think it's a
wonderful standard game and it's a game
that I would actually recommend to
people who don't necessarily play Metal
Gear Solid games which you couldn't say
for a lot of other sort of deep
franchise titles and you're the one
talking about it a lot on this set here
Danny but during our discussions I mean
there were dust we had over a dozen
people down there at any given time and
a lot of them were also talking sharing
their stories about this mission or that
mission or about how this challenge or
that challenge sort of it just like
invigorated them and to thought made
them think this game was just such a
great sandbox in such a such an
excellent experience it's worth
mentioning that there are four of us
sitting here in this room talking about
these games but when we were downstairs
there was something close to twenty odd
I think yeah as though a lot of thought
and time went into these and nominee
list and our final one for Xbox one is
again we've heard a bunch about today
and a wonderful game on a bunch of
platforms but it definitely also stood
out on the xbox one far cry 4 hagan man
amazing there's just so much as a John
Dame hey Jake Ellis hey Jay got it AJ
Gandhi they say it both ways don't they
yeah yeah cuz he says his American Way
and then they come in with his his
regional way it's pretty good yeah a fun
game absolutely loads to do what do you
think it was about this game that sort
of made it so entertaining considering
its using a formula that we've seen
Ubisoft use a lot this year you know and
worth mentioning there's no sign of so
far of either watch dogs or AC unit e on
this list you can set a tiger on fire
and you can get on an elephant and write
it into battle yeah I can control it
like a Jeep yeah like a Kia also the map
editors like actually really robust and
a lot of fun i know we played on we
played on this show with mary a couple
weeks back where that we had the bears
bear explosion and stuff like that if
people get so creative with it like it's
pretty solid yeah and a great shooter to
boot as well
I think for me the gun Zenith the AI is
you know not necessarily the most
complex thing but it replays it that a
sort of fun open nature of that game and
it's a game that a lot of us are still
playing and still trying to complete at
the moment is still enjoying also a
wingsuit wingsuit anak yeah and it's a
straight up gives you a wingsuit right
from the off please give me more wing
Susan video games thank you very much we
see this game sincerely chris waters
those are our five nominees for best
xbox one video game of the year and we
will be revealing the winner of that as
well as the winner of the xbox 360 on
december 16th right here on gamespot